where does got out that I'm in Murphy's
and the hotel and restaurant are full of
people I feel sorry for all of them job
is running the kitchen kids burn Kevin
is getting busy in the bar and Bryan is
overseeing the dining room
into the gear nice Quixote's huh isn't a
deer cheese Gris huh yeah I mean so
guess trying to check in are left to
fend for themselves
[Music]
is every okay
we went up to the front desk and there's
nobody there so target Jagger
there's one of the others goodbye I
guess it is arrived to check in if you
get Brian knows Kevin about I guess
checking in well guess checking out
would you please I'm sorry excuse me you
have to come looking for us in the bar
says what happens when guests come in
late they go to the bar looking for yet
said is how we do I give it them that
checked in and then found the reception
clothes and went into the bar a little
quickie
no I've actually only stayed at hotels
probably only a matter of twenty times a
mile entire lights a new hotel I don't
know yeah so how come you guys have
anybody up here we got the bartender's
or servers like me sometimes taking care
of it once guests get to the rooms
they're in for another unpleasant
surprise
[Music]
let's wait for the drunkards to go home
before we
[Applause]
very annoying the owners ignorance is
evident in everything I've seen so far
I'm curious to see what it's like in the
past I haven't seen like the walk-in
fridge
raw pork cooked chicken sat next to each
other [ __ ] disgusting
oh [ __ ] seen this before I find I knit
it's not
the mold going on their lockers bloody
hell as model at the sides to Jesus
Christ a looker the [ __ ] mold on that
this is absolutely disgusting
Valen
so the walk in how often is that fridge
cleaned out like rightfully twice a week
yes
everything else yes yes come with me all
of you all right especially owners
sounds good
sounds good bro [ __ ] you now
oh wow oh wow look at moldy tortillas
there should not be [ __ ] any moldy
[ __ ] food it's like an horrible
when was this nice not Saturday no I
needed smell that ain't nataas that I
know that I'm this terrible just be
[ __ ] ashamed Thanks okay no it's not
okay what is that we taught a black mole
what's that supposed to be Thai chili
marinade my chili marinade bound up it's
been used in a while the sauces was from
a chef that had been there like in two
thousand six or seven or something
isn't exactly the same way as you run
this [ __ ] hotel you don't give a [ __ ]
I gave you [ __ ] I give a [ __ ] hey this
is your dream I'm running a hotel
Manning up I look like [ __ ] owners
what we are this is [ __ ] unacceptable
and it's not gonna happen anymore
have you checked out because you should
do it save these two [ __ ] it he's not
checked out he's talked I have checked
out and I do obviously I need to pay
more attention and do better at my job
how many you can run a [ __ ] business
Jim Irsay three CEOs three general
managers Oh three [ __ ] Executive
Chefs
ah it's like doing dice are you guys
reading the [ __ ] owners true story
[ __ ] off